also this morning voters in iran are
electing a new president
who will still be under the control of
religious leaders the election comes in
the middle of talks on reviving the
nuclear deal with the u.s and other
countries
and voters there are still more
concerned about the country's severe
economic
troubles elizabeth palmer is in iran's
capital this morning for us liz good
morning to you
good morning in conservative areas of
iran with a large religious population
voters have already begun showing up you
can see some of them at this tehran
polling station behind me
but the question is how many of the 60
million
eligible voters overall will actually
bother to cast a ballot
the authorities are worried about an
embarrassingly
low turnout the leading presidential
candidate ibrahim raisi
has no appeal for many middle-class
people
or especially the young he's a senior
judge close to iran's supreme leader ali
khamenei
and a real hardliner if he wins he'd be
the first iranian president to take
office
already personally under sanctioned by
the united states
that's for his part in the crackdown
after protests in 2009
and his alleged supervision of thousands
of executions during iran's revolution
as for the nuclear deal currently being
renegotiated in vienna
ricey said he would respect it if it's
signed
but in the three years since president
trump pulled the us
out of that deal iran has ramped up its
nuclear program
raising would take office with a
stockpile of enriched uranium that's
closer to weapons grade
than at any time in history that was
elizabeth palmer reporting from
iran